وصلنا قبل قليل الى ستاد المدينه
التعليميه اديوكيشن سيتي هنا في الدوحه
المكان الذي ستقام على ارضه مباراه بين
اسبانيا والمغرب معي همام
وعبود معايا همام وعبود الذين قطعوا
الحدود لمسانده الاسود هذه كثير حلوه بس
قبل ما نحكي معكم بدنا نسال الاستاذ
الشايب الموجوده معنا شيماء انت من وين
جاي من اي منطقه من المغرب
ثلاثه واحد للمغرب
او في مكان ال ال التي ستقام على فيه
المباراه والكثير منهم طبعا اتوا من
المناطق مختلفه من المغرب همام قبل ما
اسالك شو بدك تحكي من اي منطقه جاي لها من
مدينه اكادير من المغرب
احنا هنا في قطر يوم 18 قبل المونديال
بيومين عشان نعيش الاجواء
ونعيشوا الفرحه مع ناس قطر لهذا عملناها
ازاي جبنا معنا من المغرب همم على اساس ان
انا نشكره قطر ما عندناش باش نشكرهم
بالزيت ديالهم بالالوان المغربي
وكنشكرهم بزاف بزاف على حسن التنظيم وعلى
حسن الاستقبال
وكاتمنى ان شاء الله
المغرب كيف
انا هشجعهم بكلمه همام وعبود عبروا الحدود
لمسانده الاسود هذا هما وهي عبود عبود
تذكره موجوده طبعا
20 في استاد ورانا طيب انتم يعني تتوقع
النتيجه
يا اخي توقع واحد لصفر للمغرب نعم
مغربيه همم
[تصفيق]
قال للمغرب نعم هذه الاجواء كمان نشاهد
واذا اخذنا الصوره في مناطق مختلفه من
الهنا الكثير من الشباب المغربي الذي لم
وصلوا هناك سيدات طبعا مغربيات بتوقع
وصلوا الى هنا من حضرتك من اي منطقه من
المغرب اكيد
متى وصلت
طيب كيف الحماس كيف طريقتك لترجيع المنتخب
المغربي اليوم
اسبانيا بعد قليل
روح رياضيه ان شاء الله كانتمنى ااه يربح
ان شاء الله نربح ان شاء الله
الزي المغرب الطربوش المغربي المعروف طيب
انتم من اي منطقه
لانه في كثير
من باريس من من المانيا من اسبانيا حتى
المغاربه مقيمين هناك ولكن طبعا الحماس
كبير اللون الاحمر والاخضر يطغى على
الدوحه اليوم شاهدنا ذلك في السوق واقف
هنا لحد الملعب الذي او استاد الذي ستقام
على ارضه المباراه في المدينه التعليميه
هنا في الدوحه طيب كيف بتشجعوا المغرب
احنا سهل هذا مقابله تاريخيه ولازم اللي
يحضر الملعب الداخل يشجع بكل قوى ما يخليه
ولا جهد لتشجيع الفريق المغربي يعمل ضغط
على الخصم لما يكون عندهم كره ولما يكون
عندهم عنا كره احنا نشجع واللي ما اقدر
واحنا عارفين انه كان طلب كثير على تذاكر
لما قدر يحذر
من خارج الملعب
من المقائد
[موسيقى]
17 12
ان شاء الله الواحد ومنتخب المغرب 2-1 انت
طبعا يستحق المنتخب المغربي انك ما تنام
تيجي من الطياره رقص
المباراه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الفريق كما قال الشاب قبل قليل هو ليس
طريقا مغربيا بل طريقا عربيا والكثير من
ليس فقط العرب من يساند هذا المنتخب اليوم
هناك كذلك افارقه فهو الفريق او المنتخب
الافريقي الوحيد الذي بقي في هذا
المونديال هنا في الدوحه هذه الاجواء
وسنكون معكم ان شاء الله